so let's start with a very very basic
question so what is the universe made
off so we know that the universe is made
of atoms but this atoms are at the same
time based on what we call the
elementary particles the model that we
assume is the one that works and the
official we use is called the standard
model this is a huge well actually
kisses molds zoo of particles called so
you have the quirks you have the leptons
there's one here that you may know it's
called the electron you may have heard
about this one's in neutrinos that
they're related to some noble prices
actually did this last Nobel Prize was
awarded to the physics nobel price was
word to neutrino work so let's focus on
broughton feet here so the broaden has a
particular sub structure is composed of
three of these little particles called
quarks the one here so there they are
like the most basic bricks of the
universe as far as we know so you know
that these particles they have some
basic properties like mass and charge
and we're stuff and there's a particular
property we are interested in is called
the spin so maybe you know promising
physics that there's a property called
classical angular momentum it's it's a
quantity associated to rotation all
something happens very similar with
quantum physics the same the difference
is that here you don't have you have
discreet discreet levels of these
momentum so the spin is a
type of angular momentum but you know
you can imagine these are like particles
with a this vector points in somewhere
in space ah and we usually say this is G
as an intrinsic property of the
particles and well there's a fun story
about this because like the mid 20s this
theory was postulated by students Adam
fest and I mean no limbic and goldsmith
ellarum face was his it was the their
advisor and he suggested that they
should raise publication of these theory
because they didn't have in a reputation
to destroy so just go ahead and so yeah
this idea was first rejected by
physicists that there's this yes
intrinsic thing related to something
that is not directly I mean it's not
related to rotation as a regular angular
momentum so it this yes comes from
nowhere that this is how if you're
interesting more learn desserts and very
interesting paper here that discusses
that idea that actually see the spin is
really intrinsic here they argue that
it's more related to the electron wave
field and this applies to all kind of
particles and is consistent with quantum
mechanics but we don't have to go deeper
into that because this is more about
this here so this is that nuclear
magnetic resonance this is a type of
experiment that involves the detail
manipulation of nuclear screen so we
have these particles and we have this
property of the particles the spin and
with a nuclear magnetic resonance we can
interact with this property and get
information about the above the data so
here you can see a
and environment chainsaw nuclear
magnetic resonance we are called we are
going to call that just NMR for
simplicity this is they are like big
machines and you may have seen these
machines at the hospital they are
basically the same thing they're usually
call MRI machines so what is send em are
good for so maybe you have seen this
show CSI where they have they have a I
don't know what they find a dead body
and so a lot of guys like get blood
samples and and they find liquid so they
go to this fancy this fancy laughs with
pretty girls in gold son they put the
flow in tournament in the machine and
they say oh yeah this this guy was
killed by the venom of the Peruvian shoe
super snake yeah maybe they're there
right and finally they get the killer so
anyway so those those machines there
what what they are doing is is
identifying these things they got from
the things I got from the front body but
how do they do that they are they used a
lot of different techniques so in this
case the NMR is good for poor organic
materials like I don't know like a cat
or a flower or bacteria or something
like that so in this case the organic
materials have they had convenient
magnetic magnetic properties related to
these spin thing to spin property so
they are the NMR is good to use to be
used on organic things so how does an
emerg spectral look like since spectra
is actually the plural form of a
spectrum so you can see here looks like
some someone sneezed on the screen but
they didn't you see these spots but they
actually mean something so here we are
looking
a specifically molecule is called
histidine and the interesting inserting
thing here is that you can see a network
of things connected in this spot so just
for you to have a clear idea of what you
are seeing here you are actually seeing
a a to the part of the 3 D spectrum so
something like this at a very particular
zoom I can zoom in or zoom out of the
data so you are just seen a planner view
of of the thing here so well you can see
the the formula here and actually the
structure diagram I'm using our actual
Wolfram language to get all these
information here and it's it's actually
pretty pretty cool because you can get
these nice graphs from a lot of
molecules and just looking let me risk
and try something else this is a nice
molecule it's a kind of gruesome
molecule related to the stench in
corpses that's what it's called
cadaverine
instead the name oh no let me see what's
the name of this right
alright maybe we work when they so
anyway we can get all these stuff from
the burn hole here is good so yeah we're
getting all these from the actual
Wolfram language so what I want you to
see here is that what we are in
endorsing it is these carbons this is
the actual molecule and the
representation of the of the molecule
and I've number dis carbons here because
they are directly connected you have
another carbon here but i didn't put in
a murder because it's not directly
connected to the carbons but in this
particular case the experiment we are
using just is focusing on this type of
connected carbon so it's kind of
beautiful here that you can see that the
connection in the diagram is actually
represented in this the weird spots you
can see in the spectrum
alright so here comes the mathematical
part so what's idea of of these so again
we have this a spectra that we collect
from organic samples or whatever and
what we want to know is what what's
there I mean we don't we get something
from a plant or an animal I want to know
what is composed of so this idea of all
these using Mathematica to create a
database and compare all our spectral
and try to find out what's here so
basically what the software does is to
remember this is a 2d version of the of
the whole three structure I didn't blood
the 3d thing because it's like a lot a
lot of lot of data and and my imagine
will hand out if I tried it but
basically what I do here is to start
going deeper and deeper and deeper into
the data on which you go deeper into the
data you get more information but at the
same time you get more noise so it's a
push and pull thing that you have to
deal with both stuff so basically I
start going deeper into the data and
eventually get all the results together
like here so you see that they are like
overlaid pics all over the place
and when I have all this data I just run
some filters to just remove the noise
hand and get the data I I want like here
so there are some theory chol aspects of
all these said that they have to occur
so at least I know a little bit of what
we're what I'm looking for so anyway
after running all the filters and having
all these cool data here I'm finding an
Edward so remember these networks are
actually representing these connected
carbons in the molecule but the it's not
a perfect one here actually this is real
late i mean this this histidine molecule
spectra was acquired at the University
of Claudia labs and it's a beautiful
spectrum you don't have too much noise
and stuff here nart effects so that's
that the software view if you see it's
getting like a lot of networks and
stuffs but it should be smart enough to
discriminate and understand which
networks are are worth it so i use the
BMR be database to create from the well
they have just one dimensional data and
they use these to create a two
dimensional data database of reference
the spectrum so all right so let's let's
try here
guess it first a simple example of what
is happening here so this may take a
while to load alright so this thing here
this gives us running all the steps I
show you but yes in an automatic way and
the theme here is that we want to share
this with the scientific community so
the scientific community they want like
buttons and and text fields and think
where they can insert data and breath
stuff and get information so yes with
these buttons I'm just running and
getting all the things I just mentioned
on so in this case this is just one
molecule this is just a very simple
example I haven't more complex one so
I'm just getting a network it's not a
perfect network but it may give
mathematic and idea of of what to look
for so like I said I had a I need a
database of all these references
spectrum where I have I don't quite
remember but I have like I don't know
2,000 or 3,000 of reference spectra so
the idea is that should go also have
like different filters and to
discriminate the artifacts and noise so
I do remember I said that this was a
histidine molecule so we have all our
candidates here for identification and
gain I mean this one is the first one so
it's good
so I have a more complex one after this
but let me so hard in time let's leave
this for the ending because it may take
a while to load all the stops oh so
what's the workflow summary of all this
so we start with a animal or something
we want to analyze and so we get sample
from that we put these in this in this
machine here and this machine here works
with this pin property and eventually we
go to the Wolfram language in the world
language will do all the hard work for
us to identify these unknown stuff we
have there so a future plan here is to
deploy this to the world from cloud
because as I said we want to share all
these two with the scientific community
and so a problem we still have to tackle
is that these are very very big files so
we still have to deal with that too to
make a good deployment to the cloud and
actually so I've seen the conference's
these days and I'm wondering if we can I
don't know we can maybe use machine
learning or that kind of stuff into
teaching this software to look for
patterns and be smarter so i have to
mention the so this was made with a it's
a lot of the University of Florida sorry
guys I have to thank and of course also
i have just thank people from Wolfram
especially Francisco who is well he
always helps us on this has been
published here at the analytical
chemistry you know journal so it was
still have I think like two minutes for
for a complex demo here so this way this
may take like a minute or something to
to load so you get well these lodges we
have questions just go ahead this may
take a little while but the idea here is
that so what is it more a philosophical
view that we don't actually fully
understand how nature works but or why
is wise it like like it is but we always
understand the rules and here the and
the rules are what we are using here in
Mathematica to try to analyze all these
and basically what's new about this is
that people usually in this field what
they do is do this by hand so they have
like their respect remand they over
lathe other kind of spectrum yeah right
the stain that they all died on a line
yes it's just that's just that they said
they gonna learn because in this kind of
experiment you have like equidistance
between the carbons there directly stand
so i just put there to show that you
have to fulfil that here we go right
yeah I mean you can we can also
eventually from here find out that
topology of the whole molecule and that
would be a nice update for that but so
in this case I'm using that first
example I did was just one molecule this
one has like I don't like 15 or
something different molecules here so so
it may take a while to to load so what
is loading the anyone has any more
questions oh here we go so then the
scrip is finding like a lot of stuff on
and now comes the fun part of looking
for for interesting network so in this
case it can find like so this one are
boring ones but here comes some more
interesting ones right so here we are
just saying okay there are networks here
but we don't know what they are so let's
query the database
and try to see if its axis
so again this is a project down
separately from Wolfram but I see like a
lot of potential of including this type
of stuff in our language so I hope we
can do that eventually all right
alright so we are getting like a lot of
results here on they just run a last
filter we can also created like a nice
report of all this stuff okay so here we
get the summary of all these identify
compounds and then the cool ones are are
here so you see this citizen yep so you
see here this kind of will match
compounds well I know they're all much
because I know the data you don't but I
can show you the so we have also a
little tool here too so this is most
like like most people do this they they
don't have an automated way to do to
find this kind of networks and identify
compounds in this kind of experiment so
I think maybe that works 7 all right so
here just to compare the results we find
with the actual theorical values and and
the stuff we got from the database we
have this little tool where you can so
this so the carpenter was talking about
so these labels here correspond to the
actual theoretical ones and you can see
that they perfectly match the network so
this one did a good job and you can
compare that to another candidates that
had a lower probability and you can see
that they don't match as good as the
as the other ones yep you mean the other
networks yeah right yeah but they are
not part of that Network so let's say we
can try this one here so this is another
network with other peaks and I don't
know if I don't know if this did a good
job probably but yet all some of some
other pics here correspond to endure
networks may be right yeah some of that
so usually yep yeah usually get a lot of
noise from like the solvents and the
machine itself say again sorry yeah so
like i said i don't remember quite well
but i think this mixture has like 20
compounds or something and this one
detect 10 so it basically takes from the
paper we got that it gets around sixty
percent of the often networks so I mean
said useful number
yeah so yeah I'm wondering and I was
like I said I'd see the other conference
where they do they use machine learning
to identify pictures and stuff so it so
this is more a question for me or for
you that can we use that kind of
technology to train the software to look
for this stuff I don't know I hope we
can well thing that's it